[Music]
let's go to
annalise in boston what's up
hi dr jones how are you i'm good okay so
kelly wrote me a note on the board up
here that i look to see like which line
the calls are in and it says is it on
elise or annalise
uh annelise beautiful name okay it says
annelise
boston dating mom's ex-boyfriend please
tell me that's not right
uh unfortunately
it is are you serious what are you doing
what happened
yeah this isn't a situation obviously i
ever thought i would be in and i tried
not to
be in this situation but basically um
okay
i want to hear all of this
okay um so
i'm currently uh 23 years old i'm a
college student and
my boyfriend is
50 years old and he dated my mom
um he started dating my mom
eight years ago um they broke up
around five years ago they did it for
like three years and um so they started
dating when you were 15 before you could
drive
yes did you know him then
um
they did it for three years sure you'll
hung out
yeah um actually he's like notable
because my parents divorced when i was
12 and he was the first guy after their
divorce that she felt
um that she could introduce me and my
two older half brothers too so and
introduce her she did him she did right
okay so fast forward they dated for
three years and broke up so this wasn't
like they went out once
this is like
yeah that's what's up and then
how did you run into this guy
um so i went away
you know after i graduated high school i
went away to
college in another state and um it was
just a kind of bad experience
i wasn't doing well in my classes it was
expensive college
and you know i i didn't really make that
many friends so i decided to transfer to
a college
closer to home that was cheaper and i
was just in a really bad place in my
life i gained like 20 pains and i
applied for an internship i really
wanted didn't get it underneath things
can be you know you should go out and
just
just like
um go to industry events and just
like network and just talk to people and
just learn a lot and during one of those
industry events i bumped into him and
his silver thinning here just caught
your attention and you were like oh yeah
like how did that how did it even happen
i'm in i'm in my early 40s
like when i run into 23 year olds now i
feel like i like
it's i don't know what to say
right it it feels awkward because
because of the age gap so i'm just
trying to think of myself
a decade from now just
into an industry event
and being like oh look
23 year old that i'm gonna give that a
go i can't even wrap my head around that
so walk me through how y'all met
um
so um
at the industry event or just like
i'm just this is purely 100
almost all the time i ask questions to
get more data from my response i just
need to know like how this happened this
is this is me taking your time just for
personal gain all listeners you can just
hit the 15 second little spinny thing i
just got to know how this guy
got you
interested in him
um so maybe he's a 50 year old smoke
show maybe he's yeah okay sorry i
interrupted you go ahead
so when he was dating my mom we only met
like three times then um
like he was basically like
i didn't really have that much of an
impression of him because i felt like
you know he's my mom's boyfriend blah
blah blah but
take me to take me to the industry event
you're in a big hotel lobby with all the
little booths and stuff and then you see
this
this smoking hot 50 year old's like
what's up ladies and you said yep that
like how what was the move how did it
work
it didn't happen like that um i was with
a friend from college who also wanted to
build this thing and then i basically
was walking um i was like my eyes were
going towards like a door because i
wanted to
go to like some other room and then
i saw this man who was like looking at
me and then i had to like do a double
take because it's been a couple
of years and i was like oh no it's it's
him and then
obviously it would look ridiculous if i
just like if he was like saying hi to me
and i walked away so
you know we started talking and then
my mind keeps telling me no
and then you started talking and then
just
man okay so i'll stop picking on you so
let's fast forward
so how long have you all been together
now
um
we started dating
like a year slightly over a year ago
and your mom doesn't know it's like
yeah she does not know and i've only
told like
a couple of friends and they were all
like this is not what i meant by getting
out there like of all the men in the
world yep you have good friends um
so
how can i help
you've told me a great you've told me a
great yarn
uh uh how can i help
my mom keeps telling me no
keep going go ahead go ahead go ahead
so and yeah just wanted to also say i
didn't um
it you know we also after that event we
bumped into each other a couple other
times and then he invited me to go to
some other place and i was like this is
probably wrong so i said no and then he
showed up to my apartment and convinced
me to go with him and that's when things
started happening and um i just i just
don't know what to do
at this point because
it's like first of all i feel very
guilty because
um when i was depressed my mom finally
told me why they broke up and it was
because
she got pregnant and then he said
like uh he's
he does stuff in architecture so he says
like my buildings are my children i
don't want any children so that's why
they broke up
and then
you know and now he's saying like
basically you know he's had a lot of
health issues his dad who was like the
center of his world died so
um
he says that this isn't about
your mom i do like you and then he says
but i don't want you to do anything
you're not comfortable with but i just
don't see how
you know i feel like i'm just in way
over my head
yes okay so number one saying that out
loud i'm i appreciate it
um so what i will tell you on this side
of the fence on this side of 30 let me
just say that
um the phrase you're in over your head i
think is is apt um and i'm glad that you
see that and more importantly you feel
that right your body tells you
something's not right the reason i know
you're not okay with this
is that you don't tell your friends i
mean you're not you're not holding his
hand in public you're not out and about
this is something that is a source of
shame for you and
you haven't told your mom who you're
close to
and that that's those secrets are
are killing you right they're i mean
they're eating it from the inside out
and
quite honestly in this call i'm going to
tell you i'm sorry this is all fun and
games until
it sounds like you are being pressured
to participate in a relationship that
you are objectively not comfortable with
is that true
yeah i just i just you know i
it's just
i i feel like i you know he's like the
first person i've ever had like a
serious relationship with and um hey let
me be very clear let me be very clear
this is not a serious relationship
you are being taken advantage of
okay
no let me rephrase that this is very
serious for you
not so much for him
and
like i'm feeling i'm feeling rage
growing in my chest that this man is
taking advantage of you like he is and i
know you're 23 and the whole world's
gonna say you're an adult and this and
that
um
you're in over your head
and this is this is a mess
so
tell me what happens if you just broke
up with him today you just said hey i
don't ever want to see you again
um thanks but no thanks i wish you the
best life in your architectural baby
buildings
um you you
what would happen what would happen to
you what would happen to him walk me
through it
um
i definitely would feel like
uh i
feel like the world's kind of a little
bit ending not in like that dramatic way
just like i would really need to
definitely not see anybody for
like a week or something two weeks
and and i think he would be because you
know he told me a lot about
you know how
like the death of a father really
affects you he feels so lonely like
yeah
that is children honey that is part of
the game that's the part of the scam
he's running on you
yes losing your father is intensely
lonely
no question
um
using that as
hooks in a 23 year old
is
just not cool
that and that's to put it as mildly as
possible i'm really trying to watch my
mouth here
um
you aren't his caretaker you can't quote
unquote make him feel better
um you aren't all he's got left in the
world
those things that he tells you
those are that's a move
and i'm sick to my stomach that he's
dragged you through this
what happens if you sit down and again
hear me if if you were to end this
relationship there's no question it'd be
devastating for you okay
um
this guy's clearly uh i mean you clearly
care about him he's probably been really
nice to you
um
you all have an intimate connection
y'all are a high a connected group
you've been dating for a year right
and that's heavy and hard is he your
first true real love
he um
because yeah he's actually like the
first guy
i don't know if i can say this on the
show you say whatever you want yeah
we're way past that yeah uh
he's the first one yeah makes hey
annalise make sure you're talking to
your phone okay
okay yeah uh he's the first guy i've
slept with because
um you know in college i just felt like
i'm pretty average looking and then i
didn't want to do it with anybody
because i felt like you know everybody's
drunk and blah blah blah it's just like
and i didn't feel like the first choice
and i just didn't want to be
like in that situation so listen to me
listen to me listen to me okay
there's a lot of emotional hooks in here
this is a
do not pass go don't collect 200
i want you before
um this we're having this call at the
beginning of a week i don't know when
it's going to release but we're at the
beginning of a week
before the next 48 hours goes by i want
you to reach out to a counselor
okay with a professional to walk you
through this is going to be a mess okay
will you commit to doing that
yeah i just don't know like
yeah because you know i really love my
mother and
i know that
i i don't want to keep hiding this from
her you know that's right
um
oh man
yeah you're gonna need to you gotta have
to have some hard conversations
and you're operating from a place of
um
you're worth more than the way you have
been told uh
you're worth more than
um how much you've been told you're
worth
and
you have infinite value and infinite
strength you just don't know it and i
want you and people have not given you
that they haven't told you that they
haven't walked too long and given you
tools and showing it to you and so i
really really want you to sit down with
a professional
and counselor
because you've got some hard
conversations ahead of you
either
i am out to lunch and totally wrong and
i could be
um i think it's a disastrous idea that
you're dating
a man that your mom dated for three
years
i think it's a disaster okay i don't see
a way this ends well
some of the things you are telling me
are
cornerstone uh very predatory
i don't like it
if he wants to call my show i'm happy to
talk to him and maybe he just found the
love of his life who happens to be 25
years younger 27 years younger and knock
your lights out great
um
i
cool
but man you mix in a pregnancy you mix
in a pregnancy termination you mix in
three years
you have fractured um your choices
you've chosen to fracture a relationship
with your mom and he's making it really
really hard so you're either going to
have to have a hard conversation with
her or a hard conversation with him and
you need some tools for both of those
and that's why i want you to go talk to
somebody because here's the thing
there's other things happening right now
that you and i would need to get into
that's going to be
exceed my capacity to help you on this
show
but hear me say i don't have any problem
people are dating 25 years younger
that's all fine i absolutely
think there's some predators you don't
just bump into somebody
in a giant city multiple times unless
they want to and then you tell them no
then they knock on your apartment door
and all of a sudden they're taking your
virginity they're all all these then
telling you well you're the last all of
it all of it
something's off
please annalise
please
go call a counselor and say i want to
talk to you about keeping secrets
i'm in a mess to use your words i'm over
my head
and i don't have a path out and i need
some help and let them walk alongside
you
okay
we love you
wow